what's up you guys i'm liza Koshi and
here i am to play with some puppies
today while dancing fan questions now
roll that title slate and bring this
puppies out oh my god oh my god you've
good would you go for it I'm joy to Tori
no I got this one right now god I love
your bus speed good plug good blood get
over here get over here we're gonna talk
about this when we get home with the
these guys who are 5 to 10 years older I
don't know man oh yeah this is a lot
harder than Billy Eilish made it look go
out your episode after you watch this
one please i am i hoping we're on like
season 10 of lies on demint come here um
but but also many oh come here well
don't you love me
and the same reaction to me as men just
walk in the opposite direction
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank God you weren't stuck I would have
to say jet I think Jays our mother's
handsome carry Jessie I would definitely
have Travis and Kimiko my co-stars in
life so undermanned and then I have my
two sisters keep a real tight circle and
then to MySpace pages I made for these
two dogs that I'm adopting today there
were so many I mean just like literally
meeting my idols walking up to me yet on
a carpet is just a ridiculous experience
come back okay I'll see y'all at home um
I'm disco I am a visco girl I'm sorry I
don't have a high many scrunchies but I
do edit all my photos I'll just go
thank you for calling me back I wouldn't
have won be paying with puppies off
camera oh my God look at you it's like
you know muffin had eyes oh girl I don't
know either Anna Wintour got a crush on
me I I did a the 73 questions interview
on Vogue's channel and because I'm
getting tea-bagged but at the odd man
visits that's true yes I've had this
dream before i steam I love it aha did
that interview put Met Gala question
mark question mark on the cookies that I
held up and that was to Anna Wintour and
she answered the question and hired me
as their ready carpenter Newark for
Vogue so I did it in 2018 and then she
asked me to return in 2019 damn do I
taste good I realize 2020 my fingers
crossed maybe Anna you watch it
thanks for tuning into Busbee dammit you
got good taste girl and apparently so
it's my face BuzzFeed see YouTube
channel this is just a giant plug for
you guys oh I love this so much I think
I have to say it sir I've have a lot of
fun with Instagram but also YouTube
because lies on demands on there
[Music]
Alys characters come to life haha we
look at tiny t-rex I hope these
characters come to life on my youtube
channel and then they really really got
to come to life and they were played by
other lives
Travis calls and can be go-go and yes I
am drooling over these pups right happy
I came to real life and lies on demand
it was basically I just wanted to like
create a scripted series of sports and
have fun doing that kind of so
distracted cause all I wish to choose
between the two of them who is going
home with me tonight I don't know the
guest stars this season there have been
little dreams of mine Josh Peck and Noah
schnap are in season two these two these
two pups we do have a dog in the show
bark Paul Gosselaar it can be easily
replaced with these two guys what do you
think Oh Raven Raven Raven Symone that's
like my childhood idol though if you
dream to work with her this moment right
now when Busby doesn't you do play with
puppies lancing questions ok break
dancing breathe
[Music]
I think it's the way you perceive it
right so if it is like hey comment of
sorts if there's something constructive
about it and you're able to learn and
grow from it and someone's giving you
feedback as to how you can improve kind
of thing but also don't listen to it
what other people think of you is none
of your business and I am currently
minding my business been running it
instead this I'm in love with this get
back over to mama right now
do they need like a place to go for the
next 14 years as I have a special place
to put them in my heart or my home um oh
man I loved fine
I'm miss fine I hope they're bringing
back something else but I do love you
too
YouTube has like crazy so many different
opportunities for me it has an
experiment I wish mine was still around
so I could like scroll through my life
so stop stop fighting over me okay I'm
taking both for you okay oh yeah hey hey
I'm a good mother
girl forgot I was in any real pay path
I'm rich is your blog I love that vine
literally in your career it could be in
the palm of your hand it is that your
fingertips now you can create your own
destiny and you can create your own
thing so just really honestly go and
have fun nautically be yourself no
matter waiting and allow yourself to
evolve to allowed to allow yourself to
change and grow and be comfortable with
kind of being uncomfortable like losing
the ability to set up like a mediating a
therapy session between two of them
while answering questions anybody Lily
saying she's stepping outside of her
comfort zone and doing something so
different so amazing for you know
traditional media and digital media but
also a Will Smith is my favorite
youtuber of all time honestly I really
enjoy both it was cool this season Eliza
on demand I got to direct an episode
that was super exciting so I got to be
like even more behind the camera than
I've been before and gets you like
direct others it was just a really cool
experience and I'm excited to continue
directing things that I'm in but also
things that I'm not in maybe so we'll
see what's to come but it was a really
wonderful experience and I learned a lot
giving the most political answers like
cuz I'm concentrating on these guys
hey my kids are fighting right now q
please gonna [ __ ] supermarket in line
shut up y'all always seem jealous you
the jealous type but I can't deny you
okay so I start my stores I make my own
coffee home so I'm a good nice nice
little cold brew I mixed that with oat
milk and I pop a few stevia's that bet
I'm good to go
no kid wait don't do that to me now I
got separation anxiety girl I'm going
uncle miss these puppies no no no also I
think he's attaching now so I think he's
coming home with me thank you guys so
much for watching thank you to Evander
pompe dogs y'all make sure to go check
them out check out their Lincoln bio
don't get you oh no puppy I'm gonna take
video and thank you guys for watching
[Music]
[Music]